every business has two funnels you have  the front end funnel they get your  customers and then back in front of the  get your team it says you crank this guy  you need to crank this one and then  that's how you can scale these things to  the Moon without stopping is it harder  to get leads and sales or harder to  build a powerful team with the right  culture I think they're both hard and  both easy for different people Layla  naturally is very good at the back end  funnel I mean she's so good at building  culture but she has this thing that  she's kind of spoken over me if you are  a really good marketer a really good  salesman a lot of them are like oh I'm  not a good leader I'm not a good  operator you can sell all those people  and influence all those people you can  use that same skill set and just face  internally to your team leading is  selling and influencing a lot of it  really comes down to being able to move  people and being able to clearly  communicate what you want